isaac est un footix le champion
olympique
moi ça fait très longtemps je cherche
midi à faire parce que j'en ai jamais
fait elle a pas beaucoup qui sont un
bonbon donc je suis très contente
accès aux biens est bien né dans ton
petit jeu ça prend pas avec moi
j'attends surnom l'a enrôlé un
personnage très énergique et même drôle
à ce qu'elle fait rire je ferai aussi
diane alors que dans l'eau du bon
produit bordage
je pense parce que là en confiance caloz
qu'elle aux données qu'elle va très loin
mais c'est jubilatoire moi j'y vais pas
je décide de me jeter à l'eau
tant les prix souvent je fais de très
peu jusqu'à beaucoup 8 la chèvre 13 mois
de fioles mais ça donne tant que je
pense que le danger c'est pas d'y aller
à fond mais tu m'avais dit qu'ils
étaient drôles ou ce pas trop cette
patrouille
c'est plutôt le personnage et qui arrive
des choses incroyables mais je marie
dans un mois alors je me suis inspiré
pour ce monde plein comédie romantique
d'iso in comment jacut amis comme peu
jones ou des comédies avec des
personnages féminine que je trouvais
bien
des scènes qui sont un peu d'un extrême
comme cafard finalement c'est là où je
peux faire des choses que jamais pu
faire encore et comme le voit pas
forcément de gens
je suis prête à tout jeu pas peur d'être
vécue
sa journée à craindre
chantier fut fait